it's an Adam Sandler comedy starring
Jennifer Aniston what are you really
expecting so just go with it it's the
kind of movie that as soon as you see
the trailer you're like I know exactly
how this is going to hit in fact that
was on a podcast with grounded for life
27 Blake Kennedy and we actually had a
complete discussion about this and of
course we were correct about the outcome
of the film that's not really like
saying anything specially watch the
trailer you know what's going to happen
Adam Sandler meets a smokin hot babe
played by Brooklyn Decker he thinks he's
the girl of his dreams
but whoops she found his fake wedding
ring that he wears to try to pick up
chicks so he has to create a fake wife
fake kids fake family fake vacation take
everyone onto this vacation to Hawaii
and trying to convince Brooklyn Decker
that he is an awesome person
and this is his real family and that he
deserves her sympathy and that they will
fall in love but of course he has to use
Jennifer Aniston to try to get to
Brooklyn Decker by pretending that
Jennifer Aniston
is his ex-wife of course you know that
eventually Jennifer Aniston to him are
going to start making eyes at each other
and that does happen in fact Wow I think
that's my longest take ever Adam Sandler
has a few different types of movies
everyone so element make like a really
serious movie where he gives a really
dramatic performance and those are my
favorite things that he does I really
like when he goes serious then he has
just a flat-out sophomoric comedy then
he has the romantic comedy with
sophomore comedy mix this is that 50
first dates that kind of thing so I
don't understand why anyone would go
into a film like this thinking they're
going to get anything other than what
the trailer promises it's a fluffy
romantic comedy with you know random
little funny moments it's exactly what
the film promised it would be on that
level I enjoy
I had some good laughs out of this film
I really like Adam Sandler Jennifer
Aniston was very charming in her role
but there is a huge problem I had of
this film and it's the fact that all of
the characters in this film are huge
idiots they are so stupid
Brooklyn Decker's character is an idiot
she cannot see through any of Adam
Sandler's lives ahead of Sandler is
telling these lies and it is so obvious
that he is lying
he's like shuffling is like making a
void so he's like I mean any person
alive would be like dude you are lying
right to my face but no but no no no no
no not in this film remember how to meet
the parents it seemed like everything
just kept piling on to Ben Stiller more
problems more problems that happens to
Adam Sandler a lot in this film however
almost every single one of these
problems I saw immediately away how we
could avoid him I'll give you an example
after they meet for the first time the
girl pulls the wedding ring out of his
pants and she's all shocked and he's
like oh where do I do
he's like I'm married you could have
said something anything other than I'm
married you could have said I'm holding
that ring for my best friend who's
thinking about proposing or something
just anything other than I'm married
later in the film when he's with
Jennifer Aniston and Brooklyn Decker
trying to set on this facade that
they're married Jennifer Aniston gets a
call from one of her actual kids and
she's like oh honey this and that and
Brooklyn Duggars like you have kids and
then Sandler's like yeah I got kids he
could have easily said oh my wife I'm
divorcing as a kid with another man
that's what I'm divorcing her yeah these
characters are idiots this is the kind
of film where the characters are not
characters they're just people there to
propel the movie along they add little
possibilities for more random scenes of
humor and Nicole Kidman's in this movie
and she is just so annoying I could not
stand her character I know her character
was supposed to be annoying but it was
just and I usually really liked her
which was disappointing but all of that
aside this is just a random little
fluffy comedy I mean you are not
supposed to really be all invested in it
so if you're just looking for a couple
laughs and just a fun little disposable
time this movie is perfect for you if
you're looking for like a legit romantic
comedy that's like
really really good and like touches you
and everything then what in the world
are you doing in the theater of an Adam
Sandler comedy so I'm not like other
critics I'm not going to match this
movie just because it's stupid I have
fun with it there's just a lot of random
problems with it that bugged me but for
the most part it's a fun movie so I'm
going to give it two and a half out of
four stars